try again is that better okay brilliant
um welcome members and officers and
we've got our guest here who I'll
introduce a little bit later
um
before we start the meeting properly
I'll go through the emergency evacuation
announcement Mark you'll be checking up
on this obviously there are no planned
fire drills so if the fire alarm
activates please leave the building in
an orderly fashion via the nearest fire
exit
two fire exits through the partition
doors are currently not in use due to
ongoing Works therefore the fire exits
are through the main doors of the hall
or the storeroom adjacent to the stage
the fire assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance to the
building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
would you please switch off mobiles or
turn them on to silent and toilets and
hand washing facilities are available in
the foyer area I can see there are no
members of the public so the
announcement pertaining to photography
doesn't count
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop and for the
audio recording
these are all switched on and ready for
you to speak and will be unmuted by
officers so you do not need to adjust
them
please make sure that the microphone is
close to your mouth before speaking and
please speak clearly
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands form and
then against recommendations and we'll
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
members I'd like to request that we will
stick to the five minutes per member for
speaking and this is to allow maximum
time and maximum participation from
members so moving on to agenda item
number one apologies for absence
apologies have been received from
councilor Mike Wilkinson councilor
Richard Lamborn councilor Bob Milne and
councilor James Newport are there any
other apologies for absence
okay thank you
agenda item two substitute members
councilor Ian Foster will be
substituting for councilor Bob Milne and
councilor Jim Cripps will be
substituting for councilor James Newport
so welcome both of you
agenda item three non-members attending
we have councilor Arthur Williams
councilor Daniel F day and councilor
Simon Woodland so welcome to you all
agenda item four is minutes of the
meeting held on the 23rd of February
2023. members the minutes are not yet
available so they will be taken at the
next meeting on the 4th of April
agenda item five to receive decorations
of interest and any whipping
declarations are there any Declarations
of Interest members
okay thank you
agenda item six is an update on the
Gypsy and travelers members there's two
updates from the Essex county-wide
traveler unit dated the 25th of November
2022 and the 3rd of February 2023
these have been circulated
updates are generally sent out when
there are encampments within the county
so it's not really a case of asking for
something within the Rochford area if
there's been no encampments there is no
report
but members do you have any questions or
observations on the report
okay thank you no one's indicated just
just as a question
would members like to see this perhaps
on a quarterly basis the report produced
so yeah okay so yeah okay thanks Council
Foster so I would ask officers if we
could make this available request on a
quarterly basis thank you
members we've got one recommendation and
that's the Essex county-wide traveler
unit updates on Gypsy traveler
encampments within the county be noted
is that noted members
okay thank you
um
we now move on to agenda item seven
which is the community safety
partnership and before I asked Tracy
Lily the director of communities and
health to introduce a report I'd like to
welcome station manager Mark Elliot who
is the station manager for Rochford and
hawkwell fire stations thank you you're
most welcome so Tracy
could ask you to introduce the report
thank you chair oh that was loud
um as members will know we report
annually on the work of the CSP and we
bring it to this meeting it kind of says
what it does on the tin in the report
itself as you can see we get funding
from the pfcc office of just over 12 000
pounds it is a joint CSP and through
that amount of funding we're able to
contribute to different projects that
you can see in the report itself I'm
happy to answer any questions one of the
things that I just wanted to address for
members is it's fantastic having Mark
here but we haven't got the other
invitees to this meeting unfortunately
they've had to give their apologies due
to other commitments what we want to do
moving forward is have a twice yearly
meeting where the CSP will come and that
will be senior officers the pfcc's
office a senior police officer and
myself and we'll have a panel where
we'll invite all members to that and
they can we can present the work of the
CSP and also ask questions on the work
that's undertaking because I think it's
important to engage with all members on
the work of the CSP so I just wanted to
kind of put that out there and also
moving forward
I'd like to change the way that we
report back to this group and there will
be an appendix to the report detailing
more information for members to have a
look at rather than just the stuff that
we fund I think it's important to give
members a bit more detail but happy to
answer any questions
thanks before I asked members
um
if they've got any questions or
observations can I just be clear
do you still foresee the CSP coming back
once a year to be reported at the
overviews group committee
yeah that's a requirement we were
supposed to set up all csps are supposed
to set up a crime and disorder committee
to overview and scrutinize the work of
the CSP and it's agreed that this
committee will do that so that report
will still come back to this committee
but we'll have the twice yearly meeting
where all members can ask questions of
our key Partners okay thank you any
cancer Reeves
thank you chair uh just one question
really the 12 000 odd pounds that we get
in grant funding this is quite a serious
um area of concern for the area
um being
the sort of um
uh the way that Society is going these
days I'm just wondering do you think
that that is sufficient is that
something that I know every penny of it
has been spent is that something that
you think we should be looking for
additional funding on
um are there any projects that would
benefit from additional funding is that
something that the council you think
should be looking towards
it's like more money but it is what it
is we get that funding from the pfcc
it's distributed across Essex different
areas get different parts but there are
other funding opportunities available
that we can bid into
and we do that quite regularly but yeah
we definitely like more but it's about
having that clear
priority areas that you want to Target a
clear kind of direction of where you
want that money to be spent and then
what you can do is work with the
partners that you have and you can go
out for extra funding so the pfcc's
office offer extra funding for different
projects and it's incumbent on us as a
CSP to make sure that we tap into those
funding streams that are available
thank you
councilor Foster
thank you chairman
um similar subject really on 4.2 where
it says delivery continues to be
dependent on that Grant do we know
whether the police and fire and crime
commission has actually budgeted for
that in this coming year
sorry yes they have that comes through
every year from the pfcc's office
council Mrs McPherson
thank you chair
um Tracy a couple of things
um the priorities for uh the 2020 223
were identified to domestic abuse
violence against women and girls and
social behavior violence including knife
crime and hate crime as mentioned on 3.2
and also then on 3.8 do these mirror the
priorities from the pfcc yeah I thought
they would do
um so have we got the priorities now for
23 24 that would be my first question
the next one is regarding the grant of
um just over 12 000
councilories several years ago it was a
lot more trust me
um
I would like to know because we are a
joint cfp
is that funding per CSP regardless that
we are joined so if we were separate
would we get that amount or would we
only get half of that I.E if you're a
separate District such as uttlesford do
they just get the same 12 000 or do they
get six and how has that been spent
across the two districts then I've got a
couple more after those if that's okay
in terms of the funding the funding is
allocated per locality area so
I haven't been involved in the CSP
before now but you get one pot of money
it would potentially be split if you
were not in a merger with castlepoint so
that's that situation in terms of the
priorities that these are the draft
priorities
um that are going to be repeated again
this year but it's for the CSP to make a
final decision on whether they will be
the final
priorities but I'd Hazard a guess that
they will remain the same because
they're very key priorities and they tie
in with the police fire and crime
Commissioners crime plan
and just bear with me I can't remember
the next question
um I think you've I think you've just
covered it oh good but but when you say
um per locality so Brentwood is a CSP on
its own do they get 12 000 337
um each locality gets different amounts
okay so it is still based on the number
of people yeah yeah okay
um okay the other couple of points I
wanted to raise was um you mentioned the
pfcc separate pot that we can bid for
have we done that successfully in the
past
I'm not sure what's happened in the past
for Rochford but definitely moving
forward that's something that we will do
I'm very passionate about taking funding
that's out there and I think sometimes
it's it's difficult when you've got a
small team and Andy only works part-time
so yeah that will be something that will
be definitely tapping into and what I
would say is a benefit from having the
joint CSP is that you can commission
services and projects across both areas
so there is a kind of saving to be had
there so it's not you know there's quite
positive on occasion
through you again chair as we move
forward and that appendix is going to be
produced in future to support this um
report the
other question that you're right who
there was one part needed an answer
um the breakdown of the CSP money would
be useful to see how that is spent
and just
um for noting 3.4 bar and bass the
provision that you have popped down
there is across the district I'm sorry
I've raised this before he is not across
the district my ward in Sunny grade wake
ring has never seen the Byron bus and
they will confirm that to you
thank you chairman
thank you
any other members
okay there's um
could I
could I raise just a general Point
really is that the report's got a number
of acronyms in could it be possible to
have a glossary or an appendix at the
back of it just so that people know what
what those are
yeah like I said moving forward the
report will be a lot more comprehensive
and concise and there's always a
glossary attached to break down some of
those acronyms for you okay thank you
um I've got a question because and it's
for you mark as as we've got you in
front of us very often our focus when we
when we talk about the community safety
partnership the emphasis is often seen
to be on the police service but from
your perspective can you tell tell us a
bit about how the fire service
contributes towards that
uh yeah sure nobody said thank you very
much for inviting me tonight through um
Andy
um
through the CSP we've got numbers for
initiatives we have volunteers in the
S65 service we conduct safe and World
visits I've got some figures who helps
you from the first of November to the
first of February about how we've gone
to education into the schools and then
we've worked with schools we've got our
in fireworks cyber safety and gangs we
hit 2085 young people in the last three
months in Rochester district and Castle
point if that is all information
we've conducted 81 South and wealth 81
so safe and well visits those trained
volunteers who go in and look at
burglaries help prevent burglaries in
the home we've done home fire safety
checks 53 we do risk-based revisits
where we've been out to people two or
three years ago and we've Revisited them
to make sure they're still safe in their
homes
we've carried out sensory 16th century
inspections for people to keep them safe
in their home who have required maybe a
red flashing light instead of a smoke
detector because of the hearing loss and
the vibrating pads under beds on the
pillows and things like that and we've
just done various work through that
we've also we've set up something called
fire Stoppers which is a phone line that
people can phone up is to if there's
been deliberate fires in here and they
want to anonymously give information
over to that and then we can sort of
work with the police to then sort of
track that down
thank you
any members cancer rings have you got a
question for the station officer station
manager sorry
yeah thank you very much for coming
tonight Mark and uh thank you for uh
that contribution
um the question that right that your
contribution raises to me is that it
seems to me that you're doing an awful
lot of work there
um is that all covered by the grant that
actually is coming out or is that
something that is internal from the fire
brigade
uh good question
I could pass you over to my learning
colleague I'm from the operational side
so they're managing fire stations so I
couldn't read the budget I think that's
just all part of the community safety
budget there might be some more
information that my colleague can give
you regarding that
confident to say that that's actually
all part of the fire service ongoing
budget and anything additional to that
because they have a great um
project within the schools and they do a
lot of work they're not just about the
fire service and it goes back to the
report that you will get in future which
will give you you know breakdown of some
of the good work that our partners do
but yeah that is actually funded by the
fire service
thank you council Mrs McPherson
thank you chairman
um Mark um fire break courses one are
they still going
um bearing in mind the hot weather that
we've had there were fires started I
noticed I'm just saying down in my ward
again because it's quite rural
um are they still going
if they're not is this something that we
could tap into this probably a question
for Tracy with the pfcc funding going
forward that we deliver more of those
thank you
hello
that's it yeah as far break still is
going ahead and everything but um
obviously probably as you know you've
quite a lot of pressure on these courses
and a lot of children want to be
involved in young people want to be
involved in the schools want to have
have that sort of queuedos as well to
have it in their schools and so it still
goes ahead the pressure on the places is
quite overwhelming to be honest
councilor constable
yeah thank you Mr chairman I think uh
councilor McPherson's just asked my
question for me
okay are there any other questions or
observations
Council Williams
thank you chairman yeah I would just
like to thank long for coming along it's
the most useful thank you and of course
once again I'd like to thank Tracy does
an amazing job thank you
and uh thank you thank you very much
um members there's one recommendation
set out at paragraph 9.1 on page 7.4 of
the report which is to note the progress
made by the Rochford District Community
safety partnership during 2022 2023 is
that noted members
okay thank you
station manager edit thank you for
coming
um you're welcome to stay for the rest
of the meeting but if you want to
go let's do but thank you for your
attendance no no thanks for watching
join me I'm on operation availability so
I can go back on the run then as well so
I want 24 hours so I can go back and do
the fire calls and everything but no
it's nice to meet you all thanks very
much
sorry sorry one more Finch here so I've
bought a selection of fire safety
leaflets and information which I'll
leave out I know if you have offices
that you want to sort of I'll leave it
just here 45 seconds okay lovely thank
you
thank you
um moving on to agenda item eight the
one team transformation program
strategic partnership with Brentwood
Borough Council quarter four update Greg
Campbell the director of policy and
delivery will sorry introduce a report
Greg over to you
no sorry cancel sorry cancel what I
thought you were sorry Council of
Wharton the leader of the council will
introduce
chairman thank you very much indeed it
was all designed to confuse you while I
was over there and Yvonne was sitting in
this seat but uh thank you good evening
uh members good evening officers thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
introduce item eight which as the
chairman has said is quarter for update
in respect of the one team
transformation program and the Strategic
partnership we're just over one year
into our strategic partnership with
Brentwood Borough Council an awful lot
has been achieved in terms of putting
the structure in place tier one tier two
and tier three appointments have been
made that is of course the chief
executive the Strategic directors and
the directors nine directors where we're
at at the moment is we have six
permanent appointees to those posts and
three interim and that has enabled us to
progress with our operations
and at least get the structure in place
but there are further interviews planned
over the next few weeks to complete the
tier three process
um
the report before you this evening is
really looking at service updates that
your appendix one has got the risks
register and risk and issues register
and it will be fair to say that I think
part of the integration process is
understanding the culture's historic
cultures between Brentwood and Rochford
and picking the best out of those
cultures and aligning the two and I
think we should be actually very proud
of progress that we've made in a
relatively short period of time because
you know these things don't happen that
swiftly and certainly it's been
acknowledged in a number of quarters how
well the process is going the
integration the partnership and
obviously the benefits that we can
achieve through financial benefits as
well as the integration of delivering
service and as I always say our
principal objective here in the council
is to submit to ensure the lives of our
residents and businesses are even better
than they currently are so that is the
fundamental objective chairman thank you
very much indeed
is there anything you'd like to
highlight on the report
evening chairman evening members nothing
further to highlight on the report is
before you to note available obviously
for questions about anything okay thank
you any members wishing to speak
Council Foster
thank you chairman one small question on
page 8.4 3.9 which talks about the
face-to-face meetings with staff it says
over 200 participated it's that 200 out
of how many in total as a matter of
Interest
so so that is around about 400 in total
Brentwood and Rockford staff in total so
if you think two public meetings or two
face-to-face meetings one at Freight
house was very well attended one at
Brentwood Council was well attended and
then we had an online version for all
those who couldn't make it so that's one
of the highest number uh that we've had
to those meetings so far and there was
some good discussion that those meetings
I would say
cancel the shop
hmm can you hear me
um is there a date set for the approval
of the business case
so chair sorry councilor is it a
specific so
the business case is just so unclear so
the expected date of the business case
completion is in the third column so
that's when we're expecting the business
case to be completed no sorry yeah and
then after that once it's done the
implementation gets into place
and and if I can come in there please
chairman just to add to that we have to
bear in mind it is broadly a 24-month
program and we're about 13 months into
it with the Individual Services as Mr
Campbell has said showing the estimated
time for completion in that third column
hopefully that answers your question
Mrs Gadsden
I would just like to address
congratulate the leader on this
initiative of the partnership I think
it's an excellent idea
um I'm very impressed with the officers
that have joined and on the whole I
think it's going really well and well
towards helping the cut the council with
its budget restraints so I think a well
done
okay
yeah if I can come back on that point
please chairman and say that clearly the
spotlight has been on Brentwood and
Rochford nationally
um because there are all sorts of
Partnerships going on and there are few
where you don't have a joining
boundaries and we always made clear at
the outset that the sovereignty of Roger
District Council was Paramount in all
this as indeed did Brentwood
um but my interest is obviously Rockford
um but there are many councils now that
are looking at the success of our
partnership the benefits that it's
providing and along with our budget
they're actually looking at us with some
degree of envy that they're not in a
similar partnership given the
constraints on local government at the
present time thank you very much indeed
thank you any other members wishing to
speak
um I've got a question if I may which is
is to do with risk management so if we
look at the report with the risks the
risks seem to be moving in the right
direction so with lots of red risks and
we've now moved them down to Amber so
is it fair to say that our confidence in
achieving this is is increasing as we go
along
thank you chair
um what I would say as we keep an eye on
those risks regularly
um confidence is higher that we can
achieve what we're setting out to do
um we're going definitely in the right
direction we've got the first phase as
you can see in the report taking those
service reviews we then go into the
second phase in May and I think we're
definitely on the right lines to achieve
what we have set out to achieve against
that agenda okay thanks and I've got a
follow-up question on risk which is have
any new risks been identified since the
start of the program
so we've had a couple of new ones added
the latest one was the ICT one which was
part of the original request and we were
doing that and I think it was the second
or third quarter we undertook that
review with both ICT services and that
has been added which is risk my eyes are
25.
thank you Mr Summers whose eyes are
better than mine
yeah so that was one that was added okay
thank you anyone else wishing to speak
okay
um in that case members
um
we've got the recommendation on the
report
at paragraph 11.1
on page 8.5 and the recommendation is
that the committee notes the progress of
the one team transformation program
is that noted members
okay thank you very much
moving on to a gender item nine which is
the review of improvements within the
development management team we've undone
the planning manager we'll introduce the
report
Yvonne
thank you very much
right good evening members and thank you
chair
um so yeah so as you can see item nine
is report on the review of the
improvements that have occurred over the
last three years in the development
management team
and also what this report does cover is
what future improvements we intend to
actually make to the service
so um just to give you a quick overview
here is that in October 2019 the
development management service within
the council was actually
underperforming we have a central
government targets that we have to meet
with the time that we take to determine
planning applications and there are
targets set there there's 70 percent of
major development at six or eight sixty
percent of major applications and 70 of
any other application that we have to
determine within the 13 week and eight
week time scales for those applications
and at the time the planning department
at Rochford were only performing
um 70 percent of major applications and
around about 74 on the other types of
applications so we were sort of sailing
Paris Lee close to
um you know that
um target line so we actually invited
the plan advisory service to come in to
do an overhaul of the service that was
being offered and to actually help us
with some suggestions as to how we might
look to improve our performance now I
will add that the performance was
largely due to the fact that we were
having been through a very lean period
of staff I think from sort of 2017 to
2019 we'd been down to
senior officers and they hadn't been
replaced so
um would obviously you know impact on
workload and actually affected our
targets and our achievements our
performance so
um plan advisory service came in they
suggested a list of improvements that we
make and we put those in place and they
have over the last sort of two two and a
half years actually
increased our performance quite
substantially we now achieve a hundred
percent on a major applications within
time and also on our other apps
applications that's minor and other
applications
um we're achieving around about 90 in
time so we've made a vast Improvement
but also what was included in the review
was other suggestions of how we could
make our service more efficient there
was quite a long list we took on
probably 70 of those suggestions the
other 30 wasn't really
the Rochford way of doing things we sort
of you know did consult with various
members and other lead officers and they
wasn't Keen for some of those suggested
changes to occur so that was in 2019 and
then obviously in April last year we had
a further review by a company called
mondren which are a non-profit
organization and they came in and
specifically looked at the workload that
we had in hand and the amount of
resource and what that actually
demonstrated is is that the amount of
work that we have in progress at
Rochford in the planning department was
too high for the amount of staff that
we've got so the actual recommendation
from that was that there was a case to
be made for additional resource which we
have put in a staff and request form for
for additional resource but obviously
with the one team service reviews going
ahead then obviously there could be
opportunities for efficiencies with the
one team where both authorities help
each other out with resource so
um it's an ongoing
um situation for us I mean as my role as
planning manager I'm consistently trying
to look at ways to make the service more
efficient but also to still maintain
that quality of service for our
customers you know we've experienced a
period where we were receiving a lot of
complaints with the service a couple of
years ago and those complaints have
definitely diminished
um you know we still get some complaints
people complain it's the nature of the
Beast unfortunately in planning
um but we've got you know in mind
further improvements that we want to
make which we've actually put here in
the report for your consideration so I
hope that helps I'm hoping to take any
questions any members wishing
councilories
thank you chair I spoke to Greg briefly
uh before the meeting there is a bit of
a serious issue with our website
um at the moment with access access to
plans and this this is a concern from my
point of view because obviously the
public don't have ready access to the
planning applications that go in that
they legally should have I know we have
a workaround in place at the moment
where the public can write in and ask
for those plans to be uh brilliant but
it's not I would say user-friendly at
all this has now been going on since the
turn of the year I I realize this is an
external problem but I would like it to
go on record that this cannot go on and
something must be done if this company
is not performing then we should explore
ways of actually getting out of the
contract and getting someone else into
it because it's just not good enough
thank you
for
ask Yvonne to respond would that fall up
we've got a recommendation
um which is to improve the customer
experience through online improvements
and digital technology would that cover
Council leaves his point it's not
something that I've got any direct
control over I mean that the
recommendation there on the uh on the
report is more that what the planning
department can do to improve the
performance and just to pick up on your
point counselor Eaves
um I I have the same frustrations as you
have and the residents I mean what we
have done is in the last three weeks
we've created our own web page on the
council's website and we're our now
every week uploading all the new
applications it's a painstaking process
that I have to take an officer out for
half a day to do
um but we're obviously very concerned
that although we were servicing the
requests we've set emailing out plans to
Residents excuse me
um it wasn't ideal we you know we admit
that
um and so what we've done is we've
created this additional page on the
website so what happens now is
um the applicant will go to the original
page where they would have actually
searched for the application on there is
a new link
that they can actually click on and then
that takes them to where all the latest
applications are it's not perfect I will
put my hands up to it because you can't
search for applications you've literally
got to scroll through to the application
number but it's got the application
number in the first line of the address
and on there are the application forms
the documents and the plans so it's
a big Improvement to what we was having
to work with
um you know over the last couple of
months
um I don't really know that I'm the
right Officer to actually give you an
update on the situation with the website
it's um you know it's an I.T issue and
I can assure you the RIT team have been
working very hard to resolve it but it's
it's an inherited problem
and they're looking for a fix
but we're confident that what we've put
in place now is not disadvantaging any
members of the public they have now got
access to those plans
thank you chair if I could just request
then that the information regarding what
you put in place could be circulated to
members because that's the first I've
heard of it so that would be very useful
please
I won't make sure that happens
thank you
um Council Foster
thank you chairman
I have a comment and a recommendation if
I may
proposal recommendation
um I refer to page 9.2 another section
improvements implemented and also page
9.3 5.1
both talk about interaction and
communication with members
the fifth bullet point in 5.1 talks
about keeping members informed on
planning decisions I believe it should
go further
I understand and accept the officers
have the job of agreeing conditions with
applicants
however on large and controversial
planning applications I believe there
should be engagement with Ward
councilors before conditions are finally
agreed
inevitably I can quote the blood
development
the construction access in the
application for safety reasons was in
one location in the green conditions it
was switched to the very place that the
application was avoiding for safety
reasons
the plan has also allowed hdv movement
outside the primary schools from 7 30
a.m and it went in the following hour
literally hundreds of children are
crossing the road
my recommendation therefore is that on
large or known to be controversial
planning applications officers should
seek sorry Speak award counselor sorry
try again seek ward council a comment on
conditions especially if they vary from
the planning application thank you
thank you
um
I'll just asked Sonia to read that back
so that everyone is clear because we'll
vote on that
yeah have you got a seconder for that
council Mrs McPherson okay
and comfort
able okay so the recommendation is for
large and controversial planning
applications officers should seek Ward
counselor comments on conditions
particularly if they vary from the
planning application so okay so that is
proposed by Council Foster secondary by
council Mrs McPherson those members in
favor of the recommendation would you
please raise your hands
okay
and those against
any abstentions
okay so that recommendation is carried
so there are
four and one abstention thank you
counselor constable
thank you
um I'm also pleased to see um item five
on that which is something I've been
asking about for some time now
um this mentions all the planning
I seem to feel that the enforcement side
of the planning is underfunded
um we seem to be able to keep getting in
touch with enforcement officers and
nothing coming back from them is this an
area you feel should receive more
funding from the council to enable you
to be better at the enforcement side of
things
and I
was but obviously we've got budget
constraints and I think as part of the
one team service reviews that we'll be
doing at Brentwood and Rochford I think
obviously enforcement will be something
that we'll be looking at
um we have done a review of this
committee did a review of the
enforcement service in December I think
it was where we looked at
all elements of the enforcement service
and I believe the recommendation on that
report was that
there was a recommendation that
additional resource was actually
acquired for the enforcement service so
yes and yes to your questions
thank you Council Myers
hello just referring to appendix wanted
a report
um just a couple of quick questions
really I appreciate the report some
four-year-old four years old now
but one of the things it says in there
the staff were on site visit said
nowhere if you're in plans because of
the software they had there's a question
has that actually been fixed now and the
second part of that was that when they
some staff could actually see Google
Earth and others couldn't which seemed a
couple of really quick fixes which I
assumed would have been fixed by now but
I was just checking really
I mean both of those um have been sorted
I mean what happens now is that the um
at the time we had a couple of tablets
that were being used by the enforcement
team and we were looking at whether or
not do we get tablets for all the other
planning offices but what they do now
they just download the plans onto their
phones when they go out so um yeah I
mean it's
technology moves moves fast doesn't it
but yeah they do all have Google Earth
now on their laptops but thank you for
the question thank you
um
Council Mr Smith oh sorry counselor
yeah please come
yeah please do yeah
chairman thank you um just on a couple
of points if I go to the enforcement
Point yes there are budgetary
constraints but from time to time this
Council as a whole sets the level it
sets the bar at which we enforce and
obviously there's got to clearly be some
correlation between the budget and the
level at which we enforce because you
can never have a large enough
enforcement team if you're going to
enforce absolutely everything and but I
think it's important that this Council
sets the bar it monitors where we are
failing in that bar if indeed we are
failing and we put in measures to
correct that it is no good actually just
saying ah well it doesn't matter we
should set the bar at a certain level at
a reasonable level and periodically that
bar is reviewed by full Council so I
think that's a really important
important point that was raised and
perhaps it is time to review our
enforcement measures along with the
reorganization under the one team so
that's the first point uh if I can just
come in with that the other point was
the point that councilor Eaves made
about the customer experience with our
website frankly it is not good enough uh
in the third month of this year to hear
that it hasn't been sorted uh I was
fortunate enough to be sitting next to
the portfolio holder for I.T he and I
have just had a discussion it is an
outsourced provider that manages that
but I can't with one hand say that I
want the customer experience and the
dealings for our residents to be first
class certainly equal if not better to
other authorities and then sit here and
say that something actually hasn't been
sorted within a three-month period and
certainly I would like it brought up at
executive next week when I will have
another opportunity in front of officers
to see what is going on these outsourced
providers provide a service level and I
expect them to be abided with otherwise
we've got to review our outsourced
provider it is not good good enough for
us to be complacent and I fully support
Council Reeves raising it as a point and
you have my total commitment as leader I
will do everything to make sure that
that is made better shall we say I will
put my weight behind that point thank
you very much indeed chairman thank you
and
council Mrs McPherson
thank you chairman um just to say um
councilor watan um the overview in
scrutiny did do a review of the
enforcement and made a recommendation
that he is underfunded thank you
um
Yvonne I'm hoping that this is okay I
would like to make a recommendation
that we have an additional report that
goes to members on planning enforcement
even if only toward members including
breaches of conditions
so the intended
performance monitoring that we're
proposing will cover
um info reporting on enforcement
performance as well
and
what we can do is split that
um so when we get a case where they
haven't complied with a condition it
gets a slightly different suffix so what
we could actually do is break that down
into types of cases if that if members
would find that helpful yeah
I think so chair
um yeah I'd be happy with that um would
it also include timelines so from when
it's reported to when it's action to
when it's enforced
um
we was we wasn't intending to go into
too much detail what we was going and
this is only proposing obviously it's
you know totally up for discussion it
was
um you know a number of new cases
reported what those cases were a number
of cases that we've closed in that
quarter number of appeals that we're
dealing with outstanding appeals where
we've taken formal action where we've
prosecuted that sort of high higher
level
um I think
if members would find it useful I mean I
suppose I'm just conscious that we don't
overload you with lots of information
but if you actually would find
detail of how long you know when that
breach came in and
went how long we've had it for I don't I
don't know it could it could be quite a
in-depth report we can do it but I just
I just wonder how useful it would
actually be
um my thoughts chairman are if there are
current enforcement issues going on if
the ward counselors were aware as we are
sort of the eyes on the ground in those
Wards it would be good to know about
them
and I think that's a really good point
councilor McPherson I think we'll be
happy to report what new cases we've got
um and we can identify what Wards
they've come into so yippie had to have
a look at a quick glance as to what's
occurring in your ward brilliant thank
you can I sorry my apologies well I
would add though for the committee is
that all new cases aren't necessarily
planning breaches
so um you know it's not until we've
actually gone out done the investigation
and assessed the situation so we do on
occasion get people that report things
that aren't a planning breach so just be
mindful of that when I mean I would
imagine by the time you get the report
through because it's going to be a
quarterly report
um you know we will be reporting that
I'm just trying to think what it'll look
like we're reporting that you've had had
a case in your ward and it probably
would have been closed down if it wasn't
a breach so yeah that I think let's
let's see what the report looks like and
then if you actually want it to be
refined in any way then please feedback
and we'll do what we can to accommodate
that thank you thank you any other
members wishing to speak
okay before we move on to the um
um I'd just like to understand when was
the last time the software that you use
was updated to reflect changes in work
practices or Implement changes that
would make it easier for you to become
more efficient and work
in a manner that
so we use two software packages and
they're an external provider and
obviously they do updates
um
we as an authority would then pay for
those updates
um some some updates of just minor
things so we don't necessarily pay for
that update but then when there's a
major change we do I think what we will
be looking to do as part of the one team
review is align in the software that
both local planning authorities use and
my understanding is is that the software
that Brentwood use is actually more
widely used nationally okay and I think
there will be
um there is certainly a a keenness from
myself and other officers that we follow
that same package that's in use at
Brentwood
and also to add into that that's
particular software package there's
opportunities to use that for greater
efficiencies as well so yeah and
obviously that you have some input
into this new software or additions to
the software
um so um it's actually it's not our
director it's it will be
um Sarah Bennett it's her directorate
but I have had conversations with her
and that's definitely sort of the
corporate ambition to actually align the
software packages for both planning
Services okay thank you
thank you anyone else wishing to speak
okay so before we move to the
recommendations
um I I'd just like to say personally
thank you to Yvonne and Phil drain the
director of place because
um they've taken on board a lot of the
concerns that Ward members had so there
were lots of issues there and they
approached it in a very positive and
open-minded in the responses that
they've given and what I would say I can
reassure members that
the the planning department is
constantly looking at trying to improve
the way that they work so it's you know
it's gen it's genuine constant
Improvement so that thank you
um so members we've got seven
recommendations we've got six
recommendations in the report and we've
got councilor Foster's recommendation
which gives us seven recommendations
um
members are you happy to take these uh
vote on these all together or do you
want me to go through each
recommendation
okay so
um
those members in favor of the
six recommendations set out at paragraph
11.1 on page 9.4 of the report together
with recommendations seven which is
councilor Foster's recommendation which
we voted on tonight those members in
favor would you please indicate
okay
thank you members that is unanimous
moving on to agenda item 10 which is the
key decisions document members are there
any observations comments or questions
on the key decisions document
okay no one is indicating so we'll move
on to item number 11.
um
has anyone got any comments or
observations on the work plan
sure
I'm sorry sharp sorry
um yes I I believe there was going to be
a latest statement a latest status
report on the local plan
scheduled for first quarter 2023
and I don't see anything on there
relating to the local plan so is it
possible to have an update on that
no it wasn't on our workload I mean it
will it will be on the work plan
ultimately when it
when it's um produced yeah sorry against
Foster and a meeting's about to be
announced I think for the 16th of March
for update
yeah and it would then come on to the
work plan cancer shop so once it's
produced it would then be something that
r s would be looking at thank you thank
you Council Foster okay
um so I've had a
um a request from councilor James
Newport and what he's asked for is that
a cost of living report and be
scrutinized by the ons committee now
at the moment
Tracy Lilly produces a bi-monthly report
which goes to the executive and so what
my proposal is to add this to the work
plan is not to create extra work but on
a half yearly basis so I have a report
which is a consolidation of the reports
that go to the executive for us to
scrutinize and make recommendations
going forward
any members got any thoughts or anything
they wish to add to that because I would
otherwise I'll add that to the work plan
okay no one is indicating
um so that's the final item of business
um
but before I close the meeting this is
actually the last meeting that I'll be
cheering because I won't be here in
April so what I'd like to do I'd like to
thank all the members and all of the
officers for your help and support and
your input over the year the thing that
I find about the overview and scrutiny
committee is you only get out of it what
you put into it and so I'm grateful for
all of your input I'd also like
it to be formally minuted
um that I I think my vice chair council
Mrs McPherson for her help and support
there's a lot of stuff that goes on
behind the scene which people don't see
and then finally I'd like to formally
thank Sonia Worthington and Veronica
um I hope I pronounced that correctly
Cisco yep close enough
um for all their help and support and
again because there's a lot of stuff
that they do behind the scenes which
many of you don't see just one example
is tonight seeing the station officer
there having the
um gypsy and traveler unit report is a
lot of chasing up for the officers
because trying to get information trying
to get visitors to turn up is not an
easy task so thank you all for that so
the meeting is formally closed at 2029
thank you members
thank councilor Wilson for his support
and efficient chairmanship of this
particular subcommittee
okay
thank you very much right that's it all
done